on a combien de palettes à Moisson
Montréal cet après-midi on est calé ce
matin Jean-Sébastien Patrice dit passé
son temps au téléphone pour convaincre
des organismes des entreprises de lui
vendre dit dans riz son but garnir les
étagères de MultiCaf une épicerie une
cafétéria communautaire établie dans
l'arrondissement cours des neiges à
Montréal c'est fou il manque de
diversité il manque les produits de base
quand on parle produit de base que ça
soit le riz la farine le sucre le lait
les œufs on appelle six mois
Jean-Sébastien Patrice a écoulé son
budget 2 millions de dollars dédiés à la
chatte produit il dit n'avoir que deux
choix on s'assure d'avoir suffisamment
de denrées où on refuse des gens on sera
pas capable de refuser les gens au total
multica vient en aide à 7000 résidents
de l'arrondissement coût des neiges et
pour l'ensemble du Québec ce sont près
de 671 000 personnes à chaque mois qui
ont recours aux banques alimentaires
en 2019 elles étaient 500 000 c'est pas
normal que dans une société comme le
Québec on est une partie aussi
importante de la population qui est pas
capable de se nourrir le directeur des
Banques Alimentaires demande plus d'aide
financière du gouvernement et de ses
partenaires et surtout que Québec
s'attaque véritablement à la pauvreté
avec des solutions à court et long terme
comme par exemple la hausse du salaire
minimum pour ceux qui en bénéficient la
visite à la banque alimentaire devient
de moins en moins embarrassante accord
de route j'ai compris les gens sont là
pour nous aider et nous que nous le
rabaisser
le visage de la fin se multiplient au
Québec les retraités des gens qui ont un
revenu ou qui reçoivent de l'assurance
emploi en font maintenant partie les
banques alimentaires du Québec avouent
que son réseau n'a pas été conçu pour
nourrir autant de gens
ici Gabriel prou Radio-Canada Montréal